ANDREA RUSSELL: Hi.
Welcome.
My name is Andrea Russell,
and I'm a Program Manager here
at Google.
Welcome to Cloud OnAir live
webinars from Google Cloud.
We're here every
Tuesday recording live.
And today we're going to
be talking about insight
and how you can use your data
to get more insights to drive
better marketing decisions.
So I'm going to
be kicking it off
with just a great overview
of Google Cloud BigQuery
and how you can use our tools
to get marketing insights.
And then I'll pass it
on to Johnathan Romero.
He'll be talking about 7Stars
and their success story
using Matillion and BigQuery.
And then lastly we'll
have David Langton here
to do a really cool demo
of the Matillion ETL.
He'll be showing you how easy
to use the platform it is,
and how quickly you can go from
setup all the way to analysis
in just a few quick minutes.
At the end, we'll also
have time for questions.
But if you've got some
questions in the middle
of the presentation, feel
free to pop them into the form
and we'll be here
answering questions live.
So with that, I'll
just dive right in.
And so when I first joined
the team here at Google Cloud,
we went out and we spent a lot
of time talking to customers.
And what we kept
hearing over and over
is that advertisers know
that they have a lot of data.
They understand that
the data is important.
But it's really,
really challenging
to link these data
sets together and get
any sort of valuable insight.
So here at Google, we decided
that we need to do something.
And we started thinking about
how we could position ourselves
to best help our clients get
the most value from their data.
And even personally, myself,
I came from the advertising
industry, online advertising.
I worked at an
agency trading desk,
and I heard these
same challenges
echoed over and over, I
would spend a lot of time
in Excel sheets doing
Vlookups, merging data sets,
just so we could deliver
those insights to our clients.
So I think it's safe to say
that most companies understand
it's important to get
smarter about data.
And actually, the
main goal is not just
to be smarter with
data, but to actually
put the customer at the center
of everything that you do.
So with that in mind, I
wanted to fast forward a bit
and think about at the
end of the presentation.
So if there are
three things that you
leave this presentation with--
there are three
things that I want
to leave this presentation
with and maybe
think about as you hear from me
and some of our other partners.
The first is, what are
the top three data silos
that you could combine to create
a better view of your customer?
How can you understand your
customer's journey better?
The second is, what
new customer insights
can you unlock by combining
your data together?
And then the third is how can
you connect audience Insights
to drive better media activation
and better performance?
So we know it's easy to
think about the problems,
but it's much more
difficult to get started.
And so I hope we've inspired
you to take the first step
in your data journey.
But even taking a
step back, how can we
get more valuable insights
from your customer's data?
We know that our
clients are generating
tons of data touchpoints.
I've heard one
statistic that there's
over 900 customer touchpoints
in the data journey.
But how can you break this down?
How can you start making sense
from this huge volume of data?
And so one way that we
like to think about it
is with this digital
marketing insights formula.
So if you think
about connections,
or making connections across
data, then you get insights.
And to break this down
even a little bit further,
you can think of
an x and y-axis.
So if you have a
blank grid and you
draw one data point
on there, that
doesn't actually tell you much.
So you don't actually
know what's going on.
You don't know what that means.
And if you add two or three
additional data points,
that still doesn't
tell you much.
What's really
valuable is the lines
that you draw in
between the data.
And when you start to add
those additional data sources,
the connections are the
really important part.
It's the real-- the
true source of power.
And so in order to see the
relationships between the data
points, you have to
create those connections.
And when those
connections increase,
then you create a
three-dimensional picture
of your data, and you can start
to understand your customers
more.
You can start to create
a richer and more robust
view of your
customer, which helps
you to customize and
personalize their journey
and create a really unique
customer experience.
But here's the problem.
Many of the tools that marketers
use exist in isolation.
There are some really
great tools out there.
But it's really challenging
to make connections
when you're using several
different tools that
don't talk to each other.
It's as if all of
these tools were living
in a separate desert island
with no boat, no bridge,
just hang out by themselves.
The island itself might be
great, but if you're all alone,
it's not that fun.
So we've heard from
some of our customers
that they use over 30
separate marketing tools
to deliver marketing-type
activities, online, offline,
anything that you would
need to do with marketing.
But in addition to marketing,
there's also customer data.
And that data can live
in different silos--
your CRM data, your ERP
data, your billing data--
and all of this could be
enriching your marketing data
to create that fuller,
three-dimensional view
of your customer.
So if you want to unlock
the power of your data,
you need more than just a
new tool or one new thing.
You need a whole customer data
platform, a holistic vision
that can help you to create the
connection between your data
points and pull out
the nuggets of data
to help you personalize the
experience for your customers.
And integrating your
data doesn't just
drive a technical advantage.
It's one thing to say you're
using the newest tools
and they're fast
and they're awesome.
These tools are actually
critical to staying
competitive.
And the companies
that are doing that
tend to see huge benefits in
sales, profits, and margins.
So why Google?
And I love it when companies
come to this question
because it's really simple.
So Google was built
as a data company.
We've spent the past 18 years
developing advertising tools.
We have a huge
advertising business.
And we did that because
we needed infrastructure
that was robust,
that was scalable,
that could manage a lot of data.
And there wasn't
anything else out there.
So we really built it ourselves.
And we really aligned
that with our mission
of organizing the
world's information
and making it universally
accessible and useful.
We also have a really
secure infrastructure
we take privacy and
security seriously.
And our customers
put our trust in us.
Our business depends on that.
In fact, we've hired
over 500 engineers just
to focus on security alone.
And at the end of the day,
security and infrastructure
is great.
But for you, what really matters
is getting the insights faster.
So we have pre-built
connectors that
can bring your data directly
into BigQuery, which reduces
your overall time to set up.
And BigQuery alone can
run some of the queries
that you would normally run in
minutes or hours in seconds.
Additionally, we want you to
focus on the results, not just
the technology.
So we have a whole
no ops architecture,
which is unique among
Cloud providers.
This means that you can
set up your data pipeline,
you can bring your data
in, and immediately
start to run a query
without the IT overhead
that you would need to use if
you were using other providers.
So how do you get started?
I think the best way
to think about this
is to think about the
data sets that you want
to bring in, and then think
about how you can get them
into BigQuery.
One great starting point is
with the Google advertising data
sources.
So we have a service called
the BigQuery Data Transfer
Service, which automatically
brings in data from YouTube,
DoubleClick, AdWords
automatically into BigQuery
in a scheduled manner
multiple times a day.
And aside from this
transfer service,
we have native
connectors with GA 360
so you can bring in that really
rich, site-side analytics data,
and also Firebase, so you can
bring in your mobile app data.
Once your data is in
BigQuery, then you
can pretty much immediately
start querying it with BigQuery
and start to get insights.
You can also leverage our
machine learning tools.
So we have Cloud Data Lab, which
makes it easy to get set up
and start creating
your own models.
You could use TensorFlow or
our machine learning engine,
or any of our other pre-built
machine learning APIs.
You could also use some
visualization tools,
so partners like
Tableau, Looker,
or even connectors like Google
Sheets or other spreadsheets.
BigQuery it makes
it easy to share,
and you choose who has
access to the data when.
So we like to think about doing
marketing analytics on Google
Cloud through the lens
of the data lifecycle.
So we have collect,
transform, and analyze.
And we know that
most companies need
to do this before they can
get value out of their data.
And we have tools
that help support you
every single step of the way.
So in order to unlock
the power of your data
and create the meaningful
connections that
start to tell a
bigger story, it's
important to set
your base up right
and make sure you have a
strong data foundation.
So this is really just
beginning of the journey.
Google Cloud offers
a data platform
that's architecturally
different from most other SaaS
platforms in that it
allows you to integrate
huge data sets, many
different data sources,
in a scalable, open-ended way.
We have open
architecture, which makes
it easy to bring in many
different data sources.
You can merge those data sets,
you can use machine learning.
The result is a platform
that is flexible and powerful
that allows you
to really respond
to what your customers need.
And we like to think of this
as the era of assistance,
meaning that
customers want to have
personalized,
unique experiences.
And when you use your
data to tell that story,
it makes it easier for
your company to do that.
So I hope you've
enjoyed that overview.
Next up I'm going to invite
Johnathan Romero to tell
a little bit about 7Stars and
their success story with Google
BigQuery.
Thanks.
JOHNATHAN ROMERO:
Thanks, Andrea.
Really great stuff.
So I'm Johnathan.
I work at the 7Stars
based in London.
And we are the UK's most
successful and largest
independent media agency.
So we're a full service
agency doing everything
from TV and radio to the
whole digital spectrum.
And we've been around
for several years
now and growing very quickly.
And as we've grown,
we've also seen
a big increase in the amount of
data that is available to us,
and the demand from clients for
sophisticated data projects.
So we've really had
to look at our options
for managing that
data and ensuring
that we can effectively
activate it and make
it an asset for our
clients and internal teams.
So today I'm going to start
just with a little bit
about the journey that led us
to Matillion and how we use it.
When I started at the 7Stars,
one of the core requirements
was to overhaul the
reporting solution.
The traditionally was based on
Excel with a lot of manual data
extraction from various
platforms, adding it into Excel
and using pivot tables
and things like that
to produce the final dashboard.
This was obviously a very manual
process, taking a lot of time,
and the outputs are
not particularly good.
So we wanted to automate
as much as possible,
save a lot of time, and
improve the visuals in one go.
So we looked at various
options to do that.
There are a lot of solutions
in the marketplace that offer
kind of one stop shop
digital marketing, data,
and reporting solutions.
And so we looked around
at these services,
but nothing really gave us the
flexibility that we wanted.
Each of our clients has
very different requirements,
and what works for one
client doesn't necessarily
work for another.
And it was during
this research phase
that we kept hearing
about BigQuery and GCP.
And we were very interested in
the DoubleClick data transfer
services that Google
were offering.
And we were also
hearing more and more
about clients wanting
to upgrade to GA 360
with the BigQuery export.
So BigQuery was becoming a
very viable solution for us.
It was then quite easy
to make that decision
to move to BigQuery and put
all our data into BigQuery.
It offered everything
we were looking for.
It's scalable,
maintenance-free, basically,
and we could pull
in the data from all
our Google Stack
advertising platforms.
That left us with a hole
for various other platforms
like Facebook and Twitter.
Matillion is one solution
that will actually bring data
in from those
platforms when there
are several other third party
providers that all will hook up
to various other
advertising platforms
and pull the data
straight into BigQuery.
So it's really easy
and stress-free
to get your data into BigQuery,
and that was a big bonus for us
and one of the key and key
things that led us to BigQuery.
So now you've got all
your data in BigQuery.
What do you do with it?
How do you activate it?
How do you make sense of it all?
There's a lot of different data
sets, different schemas, not
particularly user friendly if
you're not a technical team.
So certainly for us, using
the DCM data transfer
files with billions and billions
of rows is not something
you can directly work with
a Tableau or a Data Studio.
And BigQuery itself is great
for writing queries and getting
that immediate result.
But for reporting, what we
needed to have in place
was a replicable process,
these transformation
jobs that we
needed to build to aggregate
and clean the data for use
in reporting and other things.
And we didn't have a
big team of SQL experts.
We didn't have a team
of data engineers
available to do that for us.
So we really needed a tool to
kind of bridge that gap for us.
And this is where
Matillion comes in.
And we stumble upon Matillion
at a GCP summit in London.
And within five minutes
of a demo of Matillion,
we had decided that this was
a really great tool for us,
something that could help us
in the problem that we had.
So we signed up, we got it
going, and within a week or so,
we were very
comfortable with it.
We could do everything
we needed to do,
so joining different data sets
together, aggregating, putting
various string calculations
and other kind of calculations
to really normalize the data
that we were working with.
So we really can do everything
we needed to do and take
that billion row of data table
down to maybe 30,000, 40,000,
which is much more manageable.
And lastly, really,
the great thing
then is also be able to schedule
these transformation jobs.
So if you have consistent
data coming into BigQuery,
like within the data
transfer files, which
are coming in every
so often, you can then
schedule your Matillion
jobs to coincide with that,
and you have a consistently
updated data set for you.
So it's really great
to structure that data,
get it ready for reporting.
The key, really, is getting
that lean and constant
consistent data set, where you
get much better performance
from things like Tableau
and Google Data Studio,
where you've got your data
set up and ready to go.
So we've managed to build at
least 10 or so custom reports
since starting up
with Matillion,
saving hundreds of hours,
really, in work hours,
and letting those people
who would normally
be working with Excel to
actually go and do other things
and be much more effective.
And so I think,
finally, it's also
important to note that while
the reporting requirement was
the main driver
for us initially,
it's actually not necessarily
where you're going
to get all your value from.
Since we've been using
Matillion for management
of the big raw data
sets we get from Google,
you can then start to look at
things like advanced audience
segmentation, things you can't
do in DCM or GA interfaces.
So you can get a much
more specific and detailed
segmentation of your customers.
And specifically, if you are
using DBM for remarketing, then
the PLU process which takes
those audiences from BigQuery
and puts them into
DBM, that PLU process
can be automated
through Matillion,
which is a huge timesaver
because that's currently
a manual process if you're not
using something like Matillion.
And then working
with the GA 360 data
export, which is a very tricky
dataset to work with at times.
So bringing Matillion
and putting that on top
is really beneficial.
We recently had a client
brief to build an attribution
model on their 360 data.
And we were able to use
Matillion to actually transform
that data and put the model in.
So very versatile tool,
and the benefits to us
have been really tremendous.
So I'd like to think
Google and Matillion.
And now I think it's
David from Matillion
to come in and give us a demo.
DAVID LANGTON: Hi.
Hello to everyone.
So as Jonathan just said, I'm
David Langton from Matillion.
I've drawn somewhat
the short straw today.
I'm going to be
doing a live demo.
I practiced it twice
and I'm currently
running at 50% success rate.
So whether this goes
smoothly or terribly,
I hope you'll still get
some value out of it.
So let me switch
over to the demo.
Excellent.
So what you'll do, if you've
already got a web browser,
you can sign up for GCP, you
can get BigQuery running,
and you can head to
Google Cloud Launcher
and get your own copy
of Matillion running.
That's what you're
looking at right now,
and I've just started
to build a job.
And the scenario we're
going to run through today
is just to take some data out
of a couple of different silos,
bring it back together, and
make some of it out of that.
You can already
say on screen, I'm
loading my Salesforce contacts.
And the first thing I'm going
to do is just duplicate that so
that we can also load the
Salesforce account data.
Now I'm doing that in what
we call an orchestration job.
We'll have transformation
jobs as well,
and we'll come to that later.
The important point
is that we do,
despite saying
we're an ETL tool,
we're actually doing the
extract and the load all in one
go in these orchestration jobs.
And we'll transform the
data in place on BigQuery
afterwards so the
data won't have
to leave BigQuery again just
to get reshaped and cleansed.
OK.
So the way this
works, any component
you see on the screen,
highlight it, work your way
through the
properties, connect it
up so that it runs at the
right time during your flow,
and you should be good to go.
So I've just taken a copy of
the Salesforce contacts job.
I'm just going to switch that
now to load the Salesforce
account data.
Now the account data
has different columns,
so that's not valid yet.
And all I need, really, is the
ID and the name from there.
The other thing I'm going
to do is quickly change
the name of the output table.
Otherwise we'll be
overwriting our contacts.
And I'll just wire it out to
the [INAUDIBLE] component.
Perfect.
So I mentioned another
source of data.
This is Salesforce.
We could also be loading from
all sorts of internet systems,
CRM systems, the RP systems,
over and above any data
you may already be
transferring into BigQuery
via Google's own services.
So what I need
here, really, I've
got data filing Cloud
storage, I don't
want to bring in and match
it to my Salesforce contacts.
Now I could do that by
bringing on a Create Table
with the right structure,
and then followed by a load.
What I'm actually going
to do is use a tool
that we've got which will do
all of that for me in a wizard
so that it just makes
it a little bit simpler.
So I'll drag that and
drop it onto the canvas.
And I will find my
sample data file.
There we go.
And rather than having to
do a lot of manual effort
now, based on a sample
of a number of rows,
we'll just guess what
the appropriate table
definition for that is.
It's pulled the header out and
given me some sensible column
names.
It's detected that it's a CSB.
I could carry on and
make some modifications
and maybe do a test.
But for the purposes
of this demo,
I'm pretty sure
that's going to work.
I'm going to hit OK
and just continue.
Now on that point, it looks
like that job is almost done.
My Cloud storage load
seems a little bit unhappy.
I'm getting some failures there.
It's actually just because the
target table doesn't exist,
or doesn't exist yet.
In fact, when I run this job
in a moment, it will exist,
and that will work just fine.
So let's run that now.
Excellent.
So that's going to bring in
two tables from Salesforce
and also some data from
Google Cloud Store.
There's a little bit
more to do in this job,
and I'm going to come
back and finish it off
in a few minutes' time.
But right now I'm
going to switch over
to the transformation job, where
we're going to try and make
sense of some of this data.
I've already started
it, and I'm not
going to go through
the details here.
But essentially I'm just joining
those Salesforce contacts
and accounts back together.
What we really want is to
bring those two silos together,
though, so I want to
do is bring in data
we just loaded in from Cloud
storage and join that as well.
So I'm just going to
bring in a table import
and configure it quickly.
Get the right one.
And we'll just bring in all
the columns from that file.
And then I'm going
to need to join that
to my Salesforce data.
And for this
particular analysis,
my main table is
that marketing data.
I'm interested in each
and every individual that
was targeted in this campaign.
And that's the file that's
telling me who was targeted.
What I'm interested in
is how many of those
targets ended up being
Salesforce accounts
with a contact that matches.
As I say, that's a
left join so that we're
interested in all
the marketing data
whether or not
there was a contact.
Now I need a join
condition there.
This is a SQL expression.
I can use the UI to build that.
So what I'm really
interested in,
the email address in
that marketing file
equals the email address of the
linked contact in Salesforce.
You'll also see that as I'm
building that expression,
it's being sent to BigQuery to
be validated so that if I've
got any errors at this stage,
I'll know before I run the job,
not after.
And the only thing I need now
is to just bring the columns in.
And being pressed for time,
I'm just going to hit Add All.
Now I've done quite a
lot of work at this point
without really knowing whether
any of this is working.
Were those files really
loaded from Salesforce?
And we saw a preview of 50
rows of the marketing data.
But what we really want to know
is have I configured everything
correctly.
Now what you normally do in
an ETL tool is just run it,
look at the output.
When you spot a problem,
go back to the beginning
and run it again.
We've got a little bit
of a different flow here.
Because all the data
is in BigQuery anyway,
I can debug my transformations
just by running some queries
against the data that
is already there using
the code that's already
being generated by Matillion.
So just as a sanity
check, I'm going
to set a filter on this join and
make sure it can find a record
that I know should be in there.
So let's take the last name.
I'm going to set that equal
to our CTO's last name.
He will almost definitely
appear in this data
because he's always
a sample record.
And then I can get a preview
of the data and the row count
without actually
running any queries
or creating any physical tables.
So we've got 10,000
rows coming in there,
and we found the one
row we were looking for,
which tells us the right
amount of data is there
and all the joins must be
working for us to get this far.
Paid just a little bit more.
That's still raw data.
We might want to aggregate that.
So I'm going to throw on a
quick aggregation, but also
a calculation.
What we're really
interested in here
is whether that marketing
data actually led
to the creation of an account.
So we're going to add
a quick expression
to say whether the
campaign was a success.
That's going to be a
little bit more SQL.
Now if we manage to find
the company in Salesforce,
we can pick any field coming
from Salesforce, really,
for this.
If that's no, then
that's not a success.
Otherwise it is.
Now you'll know your data
a lot better than I will.
You'll also recognize that this
is a very simplified and very
idealized scenario.
But hopefully it gives you an
idea of what's going on here.
I've now got zero or one
flag on every single record
based on whether that converted.
There's no errors, so let's
flow that into my aggregate.
And this is where
you can really start
to get some powerful things.
We group by the campaign name.
What we're primarily
interested in
is how many people were
emailed, so we can just
count the records for that.
And we can sum those
zero, one flags
to give us a meaningful
number of how many of those
were respondents.
And at this point
I can also go back
see how many is going to make
it to that point in the flow
and have a look at it as well.
This has been very
highly aggregated
down to just a
handful of campaigns.
And you can see emailing a
couple of thousand people
for each variation, and
we're getting response rates
of just under 1,000.
If any of you guys are getting
that sort of response right
from an email campaign,
do get in touch
because I'd love
to hear about that.
One last thing.
I'm going to write that
out to a physical table
so that we can share
that with other people
without giving
them access to all
that raw data with potentially
sensitive things in there.
Give that a quick name.
I don't know overwrite any
of the tables I've got.
I'll just put a new one.
I'm going to run
this job in a second.
But first, I'm going to make
it part of a repeatable flow
so that this can
be run repeatedly,
and know that you're going to
get the same results each time.
So I'm going to
drag my transform
into the orchestration job
and then just put an and in
to make sure that all my
prerequisite steps happen first
before that
transformation happens.
So when my contacts are loaded
and my accounts are loaded
and my Cloud storage
load completes,
then I'm going to
run my transform.
I'm just going to right click
and run this demo job now
interactively.
That could, of
course, be scheduled.
It could be triggered on
the basis of that file
landing in the bucket
and triggered that way.
Also an API call
could kick that off,
and that will now
run to completion.
Just crossing an
extra pair of fingers.
So far so good.
Excellent.
And now all my results
are in BigQuery as well as
the source data, which
could now be removed.
And we have a repeatable
float for doing that end
to end every time those
underlying data sources change.
Hope you found that
useful and informative.
And I'd definitely invite
you all to hang around
for the next minute.
I'm going to turn it
over to a Q&A session.
And I hope we've got plenty
of good questions coming in
for that.
Thank you.
ANDREA RUSSELL: Thanks for
that great demo, David.
That was awesome.
And I actually did
go pretty well.
So we've got a few
questions from the audience.
The first question
is, what kind of data
can I store in Google Cloud?
Can I include
personal information
like customer names
and email addresses?
So the answer is yes.
You can store any type
of data that you want.
We actually have a few
different data products.
We have BigQuery, which
is our data warehouse.
We also have Spanner and Google
Cloud Storage, which can also
store unstructured data.
You are able to include personal
information, PII, customer
names, email addresses.
We are a secure platform,
but it's up to you
to decide what you want
to do with your own data.
The second question
is can Google Cloud
integrate with my on premise
systems or other marketing
systems in other clouds?
The answer is yes,
Google can integrate.
So you absolutely can
write your own code
to integrate with
your on premise
systems, any other systems
that you have in the Cloud.
Like I mentioned, we have
our Google Cloud Service,
which you can use to help
upload data in between.
And you can also
use partners who
can help to integrate
data and help that data
move on prem to the Cloud.
DAVID LANGTON: Yeah, indeed.
And in the Matillion
demo you just saw,
I only very briefly
expanded of some
of the folders
full of connectors
we do for all sorts
of systems, some
of those running in the Cloud,
some of them on premise.
We also have a
technology which allows
you to map any API
into a tabular format
and load that as if it was
a set of related tables.
So if you've invested heavily
in relational technology,
it lets you get the most
out of that and the best
out of your staff who
already understand that
by just mapping that.
ANDREA RUSSELL: Yeah.
Flexible solution.
Awesome.
So we've got lots of connectors
in, lots of connectors out.
It's awesome.
So the next question is I'm
in a specialized industry.
Can I use Google Cloud?
Why, yes you can.
So we actually have tons
of-- well, not tons,
but we have a few specialized
vertical solutions.
So for example, health care,
IOT Internet of Things, finance.
We also have
government-specific solutions.
So if you're interested
in learning more
about our industry-specific
solutions and platforms,
then you can navigate to
cloud.google.com and check out
our Solutions page.
We've got little tabs
with tons of information
on their architectures,
solutions, tons of information
about the industry.
And then the last question.
So if I use the BigQuery data
transfer service or Matillion,
do I get any extra
information that's not already
in the public reporting API?
Yes.
Actually, the answer is no.
You actually don't get any
extra information that's
not included in the APIs.
What happens is we just pull
the information directly
from the source where
it's coming from.
So for example, the YouTube
API presents the data,
I think, every day.
The DFP API has a
different cadence.
And we are just pulling
that data in and doing
that transformation for you.
The advantage of this data
is that it's a no op setup.
So literally in five clicks,
you can bring your data
in from those sources and you
can have it ready for analysis
without having to
maintain that ETL.
DAVID LANGTON: And that's
just kept up to date
at all times, isn't
it, so you've never
got to worry about that again.
It's always just there
when you need it.
ANDREA RUSSELL: Yeah, exactly.
DAVID LANGTON: Yeah, perfect.
ANDREA RUSSELL: All right.
Well, thank you guys
so much for joining.
It's been great to
have you, and we'll
hope to see you next Tuesday.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]